[موسيقى]
اسعدتم اوقاتنا اعزائي المشاهدين هذه نشره
التاسعه هذا المساء اليكم العناوين
اوكرانيا تتهم القوات الروسيه بتنفيذ
تدمير شامل في باخت وتؤكد صعوبه اجلاء
المدنيين من هناك
البنتا يشكك بالرافعات الصينيه في الموانئ
الامريكيه قد تكون ادوات تجسس وبكين ترد
روايه لعرقله التعاون
الرقعه الجغرافيه لتسمم الطالبات في ايران
تتوسع لتشمل الجامعات جامعه الاحواز تعلن
عن اكثر من 300 حاله
وهنا
هذه المره مقاومه سوف تكون مختلفه اراده
مقاتلنا واراده شعبنا سوف تحدد
للعالميه اذا هاجمتنا تركيا مجددا
فالمعركه ستكون مفاجاه
[موسيقى]
نبدا التاسعه هذا المساء مشاهدينا من اسخن
بقعه على الارض حيث الحرب في اوكرانيا
تحديدا معركه باخمت في الشرق الاوكرانيه
فالمدينه الصناعيه ما زالت مستعصيه على
القوات الروسيه منذ شهور مجموعه ترمي بكل
ثقلها العسكري هناك بينما ترفض القوات
الاوكرانيه الانسحاب منها وهو ما ينذر
بمعارك اكثر احتداما حذر منها ايضا عمده
الذي اتهم القوات الروسيه وافاجنر بانتاج
اسلوب التدمير الشامل في المدينه مضيفا ان
روسيا تمنع اجلاء بقيه المدنيين العالقين
في باخموت والبالغ عددهم 4000
[موسيقى]
بين هذه الصور وهذه نصر وهزيمه وشكان لم
يبث فيها بعد من الغالب ومن المغلوب لكن
الحديث اليوم عن تضاؤل فرص المقاومين
الاوكرانيين في
المعركه في المدينه منذ اغسطس الماضي
ووفقا لاخر المعلومات تبدو قريبه
بالنهايتها نهايه لا يريد كلا المتحاربين
الخروج منها مهزومه
سيناريوهان ثالث لهما امام كييف في باغموت
اما الانسحاب خلصت بعد تدمير الجسور
والطرق لكسب الوقت وابطاء القوات الروسيه
ومنعها من التوجه غربا في العمق الاوكراني
او الانتظار حتى الاستسلام لكن هذا الخيار
قد ينتهي بكارثه عسكريه بالنسبه الى
القوات المدافعه عن المدينه
بالمقابل تعمل روسيا على قطع الامدادات عن
القوات الاوكرانيه في قلب المدينه وضرب
طوق كامل حولها المقاومه الاوكرانيه
المستمره منذ ثمانيه اشهر استنزفت الكثير
من قدرات القوات المهاجمه حيث تسعى
لانسحاب محكم وبشروط هي من يسوعها على ارض
المعركه
خلال الهجوم يتقدمون في مجموعات من خمسه
او عشرين عنصرا نحن نبدو لقصار جهدنا
لضربهم هناك الكثير منهم ماتوا وجثثهم
منتشره في جميع انحاء الميدان بين الترقب
للنصر وهزيمه في بخموت قد تكون الساعات
القادمه حبله بالمفاجات مفاجات قد تاتي
بانتصار رمزي انتظرته موسكو طويلا وهزيمه
لا تريدها وان كانت بطعم النصر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شاهدين دعونا نتعرف على الخريطه التفاعليه
طبيعه هذه المعركه في بخموت المرتبطه بحده
القتال هناك ورغبه موسكو بالسيطره عليها
الاستكمال السيطره على لوغانسك
وبالتالي السيطره على كامل اقليم الدومباس
هنا مشاهدينا نتحدث اذا عن لوغان سكواد
هذا سر اصرار روسيا على الاستمات في هذه
المعركه اذا دعونا نشاهد ما الذي يحدث في
هذه المعركه نتحدث اذن عن معركه باخموت
باخموت تقع هنا مشاهدينا
نحاول اذا ان نعيد الخريطه مره اخرى
طيب اذا
مشاهدينا هنا
نتحدث عن باخموت
طيب اذا مشاهدينا سنحاول اذا عرض الخريطه
مره اخرى
اذا مشاهدينا نتحدث عن طيب يبدو ان هذه
الشاشه نواجه فيها بعض الخلل التقني نحاول
الاعاده مره اخرى
لكي نتحدث اذا عن باخمه اذن
اخر محاوله اذا للمدينه ايضا هذه هي باخمه
اذا مشاهدينا القوات الروسيه اذا مع قوات
فاغنر هي تحاول محاصره مدينه تباخمت من كل
الجهه الشماليه وكذلك
الشرقيه وكذلك الجنوبيه بقيت فقط هذه
المنطقه في الجهه الغربيه التي ما تزال
مستعصيه بسبب استماته الدفاع الاوكراني
هناك كون تلك الجهه تشمل خط الامداد
باتجاه هذه المنطقه منطقه شيزوفيار التي
تقوم بها القوات الاوكرانيه بالحصول على
الامداد العسكري لذلك مجموعه تحاول قطع
طريق الامداد هذا الى هذا اذا ماذا يحصل
خارج لندخل الى باخمه نفسها لدينا بدلا
مثلا في الشمال الغربيه لباخمت توجد قوات
فاجنر التي تحاول الاستيلاء على بلده
بلده خرمادا هنا تحاول السيطره عليها
وما زالت القوات الاوكرانيه تقاوم فيها
وترفض التخلي عنها وكذلك لدينا بلده
كراسنايا هنا في الجنوب وهي قريبه من هذا
الخط من هذا الطريق السريع الذي يؤدي الى
مدينه الذي ذكرنا بان القوات الاوكرانيه
تقوم بالحصول على الامداد منها مدينه
في المنطقه الجنوبيه من مدينه هذا الحي حي
داخل المدينه حيث يدور هناك قتال شوارع في
المنطقه هذه هناك قتال شوارع ما بين
القوات الاوكرانيه كما ذكرنا وكذلك القوات
الروسيه اما في الشمال لدينا حي زارشنايا
هذا الحي في العمق في مدينه باخمه تقدمت
فيه قوات فاجنر وسط قتال عنيف هناك ايضا
ومقاومه اوكرانيه ولكن تمكنت القوات قوات
فاجنر من السيطره على بعض المباني اذا
هذا كان لدينا عن التطورات على هذه
الخارطه التفاعليه اذا في باخمه ماذا يحدث
بعد قليل اذا نتابع المزيد من هذه
التطورات على الارض مع مراسلينا من كل من
[موسيقى]
الان اصبح الامر اسهل بكثير من قبل فقد
تحولت قواتهم الرئيسيه الى باخ موت لكن في
بعض الاحيان يحاول العدو الاعتداء على
مواقعنا في مجموعات صغيره بالمدفعيه عده
مرات نحن نعرف اهدافنا مجموعات المشاه
وقاذفات القنابل العاليه وقذائف الهاون
طائراتنا المسيره تكشفها ونستخدم
الاحداثيات للتصويب واطلاق النار
[موسيقى]
معركه باخمه مشاهدينا في الشرق الاوكراني
تعتبر اطول معركه روسيه متواصله حتى الان
منذ بدايه الحرب وتكبد الجانبين فيها
الجانبان فيها تكبدوا خسائر فادحه صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز مشاهدينا كشفت اساسيات
الاستراتيجيه الاوكرانيه في ضخمه وقالت ان
مهمه القوات الاوكرانيه هي الحاق اكبر عدد
ممكن من الخسائر لروسيا لان كل متر من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه يكبد موسكو خسائر
عسكريه ماديه
وبشريه ايضا القوات الاوكرانيه تلجا ايضا
الى اطاله امد فتره المعارك لاضعاف القدره
القتاليه للقوات الروسيه بدرجه كبيره ولكن
هذه الاستراتيجيه يمكن ان تتغير وتنسحب
القوات الاوكرانيه من باخموت في حال طوقت
وتم اجبارها او طوقتها تم اجبارها على
المفاضله بين الاستسلام والموت هناك خطر
اكبر اكثر الحاحا هو ان روسيا ستجعل من
المستحيل مواصله ارسال الامدادات
للمقاتلين الاوكرانيين في باخ موت وحولها
تقول الصحيفه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
متابع الان تطورات المعركه في باخمت واخر
تحديثاتها مع مراسلينا من كيف حذيفه عادل
ومن دنيتك رائد الاغبر لعلي ابدا معك رائد
اخر التطورات حتى الان في معركه باخره
مساء الخير صهيب بالفعل تحدثت عن راسنا
وخروما
هاتان البلدان او هذا هاتان المنطقتان
التي تدور فيهما معارك ساخنه بالفعل تحاول
القوات الروسيه او قوات فاجنر اقتحام
مدينه خروما بكل ما اوتت من قوه لكن
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه صلبه جدا وهناك
تعزيزات اوكرانيه وصلت لهذه المنطقه
الحديث عن نقل اليات ومدافع من مواقع او
يعني مناطق او نقاط اوكرانيه هادئه الى
المناطق الساخنه لتعزيز المقاومه
الاوكرانيه ايضا الحديث عن الانسحاب من
منطقه كراسنايا تدريجي للقوات الاوكرانيه
على شكل مجموعات صغيره لانها هي الاقرب
على طريق
وتنسحب القوات الاوكرانيه تدريجيا على شكل
مجموعات جدا صغيره يعني افراد ثلاثه اربعه
جنود كل مجموعه صغيره تنسحب الى هذا
الطريق الحديث عن نقص بالذخيره عند الجانب
الاوكراني ما يجعل المقاومه عليهم صعبه
رغم استمسال يعني متمسكين بالمدينه
والدفاع المدينه لكن لديهم نقص كبير
بالذخيره وعلى النقيض عند الجانب الروسي
هناك كميات كبيره وتعزيزات عسكريه بالجنود
وبالاليات عنها حذيفه لو سمحت
تطلق في جميع مناطق لو سمحت لاسال حذيفه
في كييف عن هذه الاستماته الاوكرانيه في
الدفاع عن باخموت قائد مجموعه فاجنر التي
تطوق المدينه ودخلت احد الاحياء فيها كان
طالب الرئيس
بسحب قواته من هناك
ماذا عن التعزيزات العسكريه التي تستخدمها
القوات الاوكرانيه ولماذا هذه الاستماته
في الدفاع عنها
مساء الخير يا صهيب في الحقيقه ابتداء ان
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه تؤكد انها ما
زالت تسيطر على هذه المدينه وانه لم يتخذ
اي قرار بالانسحاب من هذه المدينه لا يوجد
انسحاب للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وانما
عمليه الخروج التي تحدث من المدينه هي
للمدنيين وذلك نسبه للخطر الكبير لخروج
المدنيين في مجموعات او حتى على سيارات
لانه كان هنالك حادثه في اخر 24 ساعه
عندما حاول الخروج اسره حول الخروج من
المدينه في سيارتها وتم قصف هذه السياره
وقتلت امراه واصيبه رجلان كانوا معها في
السياره لذلك الان يتم عمليه الاجلال
المواطنين باعداد قليله من خمسه الى عشره
اشخاص على الاقدام في ذلك الاتجاه بشكل
عام طبعا الان القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
تقول انها ما زالت تسيطر على المدينه
القتال يدور في ضواحي المدينه وليس في
داخل المدينه لم تسجل اي عمليه اختراق
للدفاعات الاوكرانيه في مدينه بخموت الان
القتال في فسيكوفكا
ايضا غسيل هذه المناطق التي قامت القوات
الروسيه بهجوم كبير جدا وشرس في هذه
المنطقه ومن هذه المنطقه يحاولون اختراق
الدفاعات الاوكرانيه للدخول الى داخل
المدينه هذا طبعا في الشمال في الاعلى
قليلا في اتجاه الغرب من هذه المنطقه يوجد
بغداد
في هذه المنطقه ايضا هنالك محاوله
للاختراق الدفاعات الاوكرانيه لكن لم تشكل
اي نجاح هذا بحسب طبعا افاده القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه كذلك اذا تحدثنا عن
الجهه يعني جنوب الشرق المدينه هنالك
منطقه مارينكا من هذه المنطقه ايضا كان
هنالك هجوم اخر ومحاوله للاختراقات وتركز
بشكل اكبر من جميع الجهات القوات الروسيه
على هذه النقطه لاختراق الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه يعني وهو قائد كتيبه يقول ان
حتى هذه اللحظه اهم مطمئنين وحتى ايصال
الامدادات نعم بالطريقه الاساسي الذي تم
قصف الجسر في تلك المنطقه يصعب ايصال
الامدادات ولكن هنالك طرق بدي ترابيه يمكن
من خلاله الامدادات الى داخل المدينه صهيب
رائد اعود اليك المعركه في مدينه
الصناعيه او حولها بالاحرى هي مستمره منذ
الصيف وهناك استمات من الجانبين كما
تابعنا من الجانب الروسي والاوكراني في
هذه المعركه التي طالت عده شهور
الرغبه الروسيه باستكمال السيطره على كامل
اقليم الدومباس يقول المحللون هي وراء هذا
هذه الاستماته ولكن ما الذي يجعل هذه
المعركه صعبه لماذا كل هذا الوقت بالنسبه
للقوات الروسيه حتى تسيطر وهي لم تسيطر
عليها بعد على بخمه
بدايه يعني جميع المحاور ان كان الجنوبيه
او الشماليه او حتى الشرقيه من باقمت فيها
معارك ضاريه على اطرافها كما تحدث زميلي
حذيفه لكن التباين بالتصريحات ما بين
تصريحات الاوكرانيه والروسيه فالتصريحات
الروسيه والصور والفيديوهات تشير الى تقدم
القوات الخاصه الروسيه قوات فاجنر في جميع
المحاور ثلاثه او اربعه كيلومترات في
العمق ومدينه باخمت هي صغيره ثلاثه اربعه
كيلومترات هذا يعني بان اصبحت قريبه من
مركز المدينه كما قال بريغوجين عندما قال
ان
الرجال
الروس المقاتلين اصبحوا تقريبا او فعليا
داخل في المدينه او في قلبها يعني المعارك
ظهريه الجيش الاوكراني يدافع بعنفه كلبه
وبكل ما استطاع من قوه الدفاع عن المدينه
وحتى بريجوجل نفسه وصف المقاتلين
الاوكرانيين الذين ارس بتوابيت قال بانهم
شجعان ولكن ماتوا وسنرسلهم الى اوكرانيا
بالفعل المعركه من اعنف المعارك التي
شهدتها الاراضي الاوكرانيه بالفعل هناك
قوتين كبيرتين كانت فاجنر او الجيش
الاوكراني لذلك نحن نرى هذا الصراع العنيف
وهذا الضوء المسلط بشكل كبير على هذه
المدينه شكرا جزيلا لكما مراسله العربيه
من دون الاخبار ومن كييف حذيفه عادل
اظهر مقطع مصور مشاهد جويه للصف مئات
العربات الامريكيه المدرعه في ميناء
البولنديه تمهيدا لنقلها الى اوكرانيا
وفي ملفات الحرب باوكرانيا ايضا قلل
المستشار الالماني خلال حوار مع شبكه
الامريكيه قال ان الغرب مستعد لتقديم
ضمانات امنيه لاوكرانيا بعد انتهاء الصراع
مؤكده لان الوقت لم يحن بعده على حد
تعبيره واضاف شوطا ان الدول الغربيه لا
تستطيع تقرير مصير حل النزاع في اوكرانيا
وشدد المستشار الالماني على ان بلاده
ستعمل باستمرار على زياده انتاجها الدفعي
اعربت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه عن استعداد
موسكو لمواصله الوفاء بالتزاماتها بموجب
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب اذا التزمت جميع
الاطراف به بدوره قلا وزير الخارجيه
التركي ان انقره تعمل جاهده على تمديد
اتفاق الحبوب شغل واضاف انه ناقش مع
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
كوتيريش جهود تمديد الاتفاق يذكر ان اتفاق
الحبوب تم توقيعه بانقره في يونيون الماضي
بواسطه الامميه وتركيه لفك الحصار عن
شحنات الغذاء من موانئ البحر الاسود
[موسيقى]
نقلت صحيفه
بان البنتاجون يعتقد ان الرافعات الصينيه
المستخدمه في الموانئ الامريكيه هي عباره
عن ادوات تجسس واعتبر الصين قد تكون تحصل
على معلومات استخباراتيه من اجهزه استشعار
موجوده في هذه الرافعات واضافت جورنال ان
80% من الرافعات في الموانئ الامريكيه هي
صينيه الصنع بسبب جودتها العاليه وتكلفتها
المنخفضه الى ذلك اعتبرت السفاره الصينيه
في واشنطن الاتهامات الامريكيه بانها
عباره عن محاوله لعرقله التعاون التجاري
التاسعه هذا المساء مستمرا نتابع فيها بعد
الفصل
تزامنا مع رفع ميزانيه الدفاع بكين تعلن
ان 2023 سيكون عام منع استقلال تايوان
واعاده توحيدها مع الصين
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد عام 2023 سيكون عام
اتخاذ خطوات حاسمه لمحاربه فيصل تايوان
ودفع العمليه السلميه لاعاده التوحد مع
الجزيره هذا ما صرح به رئيس مجلس الدوله
الصيني خلال جلسه الرسميه لاعضاء المجلس
وبحسب تقرير للحكومه الصينيه
ستتعامل بحزم شديد هذا العام ضد استقلال
تايوان وحل لقضيه الجزيره وفقا لمبدا
الصين واحده وسنلتزم بتوافق عام 92 وفق
التقرير الحكمي ياتي ذلك بالتزامن مع
اقرار برفع الانفاق الدفاعي هذا العام
بالنسبه 7.2% الى
1.56 تريليون يوان اي نحو 230 مليار دولار
امريكي واشار مجلس الدوله الصيني الى ان
هذه الزياده الدفاعيه تهدف الى مواجهه
التحديات الامنيه المعقده
[موسيقى]
معنا من طوكيو عبر سكاي صحفي خلدون
الازهري سيد خلدون اهلا بك معنا في
التاسعه من العربيه الجيش الصيني هو اكبر
جيش في العالم وثاني جيوش العالم من حيث
الميزانيه يرفع ميزانيته الدفاعيه في 2023
بسبعه فاصل اثنين بالمئه كيف يمكن النظر
الى هذا
هذا يعتبر توسع بنظر الولايات المتحده
وحليفتها وخاصه اليابان
ولاسيما انهم يعتبرون ان هذا الانفاق
الدفاعي غير شفاف ويهدف للتوسع وتحويل بحر
الصين الجنوبي مثلا الى بحيره صينيه
اقليميه وبان الصين تحاول الاستحواذ على
تايوان واحتلالها بالقوى العسكريه طبعا
تايوان كما ذكرت الصين لا تدعو للاستقلال
لا تفكر تايوان بالاستقلال وهذا
انت تفسر كذلك التصريح الصيني انه عام
2023 سيكون حاسما في
اعاده تايوان الى الاراضي الصينيه هذا
يفسر بانه اعلان بان الصين ستغزو تايوان
او ستبدا عمليه عسكريه من اجل اعاده
الجزيره الى اراضيها
طبعا الصين دائما تقول بان تايوان هي جزء
لا يتجزا من الاراضي الصينيه ويجب ان
الصين دوله واحده لم يعلنوا انها انهم
سيحتلون لها مثلا او سيشنون حمله عسكريه
كانت تصريحات رئيس الوزراء ايضا تقول بان
لهم بان التايوانين والصين شعب واحد ودماء
واحده وبالتالي فانه من الطبيعي ان يعودوا
ويجب ان نتذكر هنا ان العالم تقريبا
المجلس الامن الولايات المتحده واليابان
يعترفون بان تايواني جزء من الصين المشكله
فقط هي انه يجب حل هذه المشكله سلميا
ودبلوماسيا يعني ان تعود تايوان الى الصين
بشكل عن طريق سلمي لكن كما نعرف ترفض
العوده طالما الحزب السوري هو في الحكم
القضيه اذا قضيه الديمقراطيه هناك طيران
في تايوان الاول يقول بانه في نهايه الامر
نحن سوف نصبح دوله مستقله التيار الثاني
يقول في نهايه الامر نحن سوف نصبح جزء لكن
الاتفاق بين التيارين هو انه حاليا يبقى
الامر الواقع كما هو الصين ترى ربما انه
بالاستفاده من التجربه الروسيه ربما يجب
عليها ان تتخذ قرارا سريعا لان الخطوات
الغربيه في دعم تايوان في تاكيد نوعا ما
استقلالها من دون ان تعلن ذلك
هنا السؤال كذلك استاذ خلدون هل هناك
استعدادات في المعسكر الغربي
اليابان والولايات المتحده حليفتها كذلك
التي تدعم تايوان هل هناك استعداد لبدء
حرب اخرى او مواجهه عمليه عسكريه اخرى
لدينا حرب في اوكرانيا والان ستكون حرب في
تايوان ام ماذا
طبعا هم ليسوا على استعداد لحرب ثانيه
الاقتصاد العالمي ليس ابدا
مستعدا لمثل هذه الحرب لانها ستدمر جميع
الاقتصاديات في شرقي اسيا ليست هي حرب قد
تتحول الى حرب عالميه لان التايوان ايضا
ترفض ان تكون لقمه سائره بنظر
بيدع الصين وبالتالي تايوان عززت من
دفاعاتها بشكل ملحوظ في الفتره الاخيره
وبدات تتصرف كما لو انها اوكرانيا وكما ان
تجربه اوكرانيا سوف تحصل في تايوان
وبالتالي الامور ليست بهذه السهوله
بالنسبه للصين لكي ترسل الى الجيوش وتحتل
تايوان سوف تحصل في نهايه الامر على دمار
وهم يرون كيف دمرت اوكرانيا اذا القضيه
مجرد تكرار للتصريحات الصينيه التي تعتبر
تايوان جزءا لا يتجزء وتحاول منع الولايات
المتحده من تاكيد التيار الذي يريد
استقلال تايوان في نهايه الامر ودعمه
الاسلحه مثلا ونعرف انهم من عده ايام وقع
البلدان صفقه اسلحه امريكيه الى تايوان
اذا هناك نوع من المواجهه المستتره في
منطقه شرقي اسيا وبالتالي الان ما زلنا في
تراشق في حرب تراشق تصريحات فقط لكن ربما
مناورات عسكريه صينيه حول تايوان لكن حرب
حقيقيه هذا مستبعد في الوقت الحالي على
الاقل شكرا جزيلا لك خلدون الازهريكم
تبعنا من طوكيو
[موسيقى]
الى ايران ولغز تصميم طالبات هناك حيث
امتدت الحالات من المدارس الى الجامعات
الان مع اعلان رئيس جامعه الاحواز للعلوم
الطبيه عن تسمم اكثر من 300 طالبات جامعيه
في الاحواز فيما قال وزير الداخليه
الايراني احمد وحيد ان الاجهزه الامنيه
تتابع قضيه تسمم الطالبات في عده مدارس
بالبلاد معترفا لان اكثر من 50 مدرسه تشكو
من حالات تسمم بعدما افادت تقارير اعلاميه
باتساع نطاق هذه الحالات
والاحتجاجات بهذا الشان في اكثر من مدينه
لتشمل العاصمه طهران واصفهان واكرمنشاه
واردبيل
[موسيقى]
تبكي الامهات في ايران على عتبات مدارس
بناتهن العالقات في صفوف الدراسه
ويصرخن لاخراجهن قبل اختناقهن بهواء مسموم
بمواد ما تزال مجهوله لكنها على حد وصف
الفتيات كريهه وتشبه رائحه فاكهه متعفنه
ومن خرجت منهن فتبدو عليهن حاله اعياء غير
مفسره والحافلات تشارك سيارات الاسعاف في
نقلهن الى المستشفيات 50 مدرسه على الاقل
تواجه ازمه تسمم باعتراف وزير الداخليه
احمد وحيدي موضحا ان صحه الطالبات تمثل
الاولويه القصوى لجميع المسؤولين ليؤكد ان
المحققين استعادوا عينات مشبوهه مكتفيا
بهاتين الكلمتين دون اي تفاصيل اخرى ليضيف
اليهما دعوه الى الهدوء متهما للعدو
بالارهاب الاعلامي هجمه كيماويه هكذا
تسميها عوائل البنات
على صدورهم يتمددن على اسره المستشفيات
وكل منهن تعاني توعكا ما بين غثيان ووهن
ودوار وسعال وضيق في التنفس
420 ناشطا سياسيا ومدنيا وصفوا في بيان
مشترك عمليه التصميم بالعمل الاجرامي ونقل
اعلام المعارضه الايراني عن المتخصص الطبي
محمد رضا هاشميان ان الاشخاص العاديين لا
يمكنهم الوصول الى الغازات التي تم
استخدامها لتصميم الطلاب
اما شيرين عبادي احدى الشخصيات البارزه
المعارضه للنظام فقالت انه اذا كان هناك
اي شك حول دور النظام في مسلسل تصميم
الطالبات فقد زال هذا الشك اليوم
هذا واقل وزير التعليم الايراني يوسف نوري
ان التحقيقات لا تزال جاريه في حوادث
التسمم التي اصابت مئات الطالبات في
البلاد واضعف وزير التعليم الايراني ان
تحقيقات لم تصل حتى الان الى اي نتيجه حول
الجهه المتورطه في الحادث مشيرا الى ان
التعليم عن بعد لم تتم مناقشته
معي من امستردام يعقوب سعيد اهلا بك معنا
يعقوب في اخبار التاسعه انت الباحث في
الشان الايراني يعقوب بتنه امام لغز كبير
من ما هي الجهه التي تقف وراء تصميم
الطالبات كنا نتحدث عن تصميم التلميذات في
المدارس الايرانيه الان المساله انتقلت
الى الجامعات الايرانيه من يقوم بتصميم
الفتيات في ايران
فعلا تحيه طيبه لك ولمشاهدي قناه العربيه
في الحقيقه يبدو ان النظام جعل الفتيات ان
يتجرعنا سما حقيقيا هذه المره لوقف
الاحتجاجات المستمره في ايران شملت عمليات
تسمم اليوم فقط اكثر من 80 مدرسه في عموم
المدن داخل ايران والاحواز لم تتوقف على
ذلك بل يعني شملت الجامعات ايضا اتصور هذه
الجماعه هي جماعه اصوليه متطرفه بدات
تتعالى اصواتها داخل ايران لتطبيق نموذج
طالبان في ايران الجماعه بطبيعه الحال
يعني هذه الجماعات المتنفذه داخل السلطه
وتوجد تقصد انه هذه الجماعه المتطرفه هي
جزء من النظام الايراني جزء من الدوله
الايرانيه ام منفصله عنها لا بطبيعه الحال
هي جزء لا يتجزا من هذه المنظومه اذا ما
نظرنا اليوم الى طبيعه هذه الدوله من
ابتداء من المرشد مرورا بالرئيس والحكومه
وكذلك البرلمان اليمين المتطرف الاصوليين
هم الذين يستولون على هذه السلطه ولكن
اعتقد وتوجد ايضا معلومات عن هذه الجماعه
هي البديل المستقبل لشرطه الاخلاق التي من
المفترض تم حلها في ايران ولكن هنا النقطه
يعقوب اي يعقل قد يقول قائل يعني انه يعقل
النظام الايراني واجه مظاهرات عارمه وما
زالت تخرج بين الحين والاخر وصلت الى رفع
الشعار الموت للديكتاتور والموت لخامنه
بسبب قيود شرطه الاخلاق ومقتل مهسه امينه
معقول يكون متورط في تسميم الفتيات مره
اخرى
الا يمكن ان يؤدي هذا الى رده فعل غاضبه
اكثر هذه المره من الشارع لانه المساله
تمس بفتيات الايرانيين يعني بنات الشعب
الايراني
وتسميمهم بهذه الطريقه هنالك مصطلح داخل
هذا النظام يسمى انتقام السقط الانتقام
الصعب هذا ياتي بعد عندما يتعرض هذا
النظام الى يعني
هجمات داخليه او خارجيه يحاول ان يهدد
بهذا الانتقام يبدو ان هذا الانتقام هو ما
يترجم الان على الواقع في الحقيقه شرطه
الاخلاق يعني اليوم السيريون التاريخيه
لشرطه الاخلاق عندما من الثمانينات حتى
هذه اللحظه في كل فتره يتم حل شرطه
الاخلاق وتنبثق شرطه جديده اكثر تطرفا من
التي سبقتها لابد من الاشاره هنا الى
مساله رش الاسيد على النساء ايضا في قبل
يعني اكثر من عقد في تلك الفتره ايضا ادى
الى حدوث نوع من الاحتجاجات الداخليه لبعض
النظام لو لو ثبت ان نظام متورط في عمليه
تصميم الفتيات لاي هدف من الى ما يسعى من
خلال هذه العمليه
هو يبدو ان لا يوجد هنالك اجماع حول هذه
العمليه عمليه استهداف ولكن هنالك نوع من
الانقسامات الداخليه داخل التيار الاصولي
المتشدد يعني في الحقيقه ولا يمكن بطبيعه
الحال كما اشرت انه لا يمكن فصل هذه هذه
التيار عن التيار الاصول الذي نعرفه وهو
بقياده المرشد في الحقيقه يهدف اولا الى
استهداف النساء لاسكات اصواتهن ولكن اعتقد
بان بالتالي هذا ياتي بنتائج عكسيه هذا
يزيد من حده الشرخ الموجوده اليوم في
العلاقه بين النظام والمجتمع ويؤدي
انقسامات داخليه وبالتالي حتى الاقرب
المقربين على هذا النظام باتوا ينقلبون
عليه هنالك اليوم اصوات من داخل التيار
الاصولي يدين ذلك في الحقيقه النظام متخبط
لا يعرف كيف يتعامل مع هذه الاحتجاجات
المستمره منذ خمسه اشهر ويعتبر النساء ان
العدو الحقيقي باعتبارهن قاده هذه
الاحتجاجات
يعقوب سعيد شكرا لك على وجودك معنا ليله
من امستردام
ردنا على تصريح مدير الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رافائيل روسيا الذي رفض اي
هجوم على المنشاه النوويه الايرانيه قال
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي ان تدمير المنشات
النوويه الايرانيه مسموح للدفاع عن
اسرائيل واضافها نتنياهو ان نهج
الدبلوماسيه مع ايران على وشك الموت وجاء
تصريحه تعليقا على تاكيد مدير الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان اي هجوم او
اجراء عسكري ضد المنشات النوويه في العالم
هو تصرف مدان وغير قانونيه
المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه رفاهيل
جروسي اعلن في طهران ان الهجوم
الاسرائيليه على المنشات النوويه خارج عن
القانون خارج عن اي قانون بالنسبه لشخص
مسؤول مثل جروسي هل يجوز لايران التي تدعو
بصراحه ووضوح الى تدميرنا وان تحضر
الادوات لقتلنا من الواضح انه مسموح لنا
بالدفاع عن انفسنا
وبعد ساعات من زياره جروسي الى ايران خرجت
منظمه طاقه الذريه الايرانيه لتنفي التوصل
الى اي اتفاق على تركيب كاميرات جديده في
المنشات النوويه الايرانيه اجهزه المراقبه
هذه كان قد تم وضعها بموجب الاتفاق النووي
لعام 2015 ولكنها ازيلت العام الماضي
كنتيجه الانهيار الاتفاق في اعقاب انسحاب
واشنطن منها عام 2018 في عهد الرئيس ترامب
وقال المتحدث باسم المنظمه الايرانيه
باهروس كاملون انه لم يحدث اي نقاش او
اتفاق مع وفد مفتشين وكاله الدوليه لتركيب
هذه الكاميرات
[موسيقى]
جلسوا تحدثوا وتفرقوا بهذه الكلمات تهكم
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان على انفراط
عقد المعارضه التركيه بعد فشلها باختيار
مرشحها لرئاسه الجمهوريه حتى الان وتعد
هذه الانتخابات مشاهدينا واحده من اهم
السباقات الانتخابيه في تاريخ تركيا
الحديث بالنسبه الى الحكومه وللمعارضه على
حد سواء حيث يسعى اردوغان لترسيخ حكمه في
الذكرى المئويه لتاسيس الجمهوريه التركيه
الانقسام العلني والمحتدم منذ شهور في
صفوف المعارضه التركيه مشاهدينا فتح نافذه
امل اكبر لاردوغان للبقاء في الحكم يقول
الخبراء رغم التحديات التي يواجهها واهمها
تراجع شعبيته فضلا عن انتقادات لطريقه
التعامل مع الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
البلاد الشهر الماضي وعوده بحياه اكثر من
45 الف شخص في تركيا بالاضافه الى ازمه
غلاء نعيشه التي تضرب البلاد رفقه تدني
قيمه العمله المحليه امام الدولار ولكن
مشاهدينا السقوط سقوط المعارضه بفوضى
الانقسام فيما بينها سيكون بمثابه هديه
مجانيه لاردوغان ان حصل ذلك وبالتالي
سيخلط الاوراق السياسيه من جديد لصالح
اردوغان بعد عقدين من الحكم اما تفاصيل
الخلاف بين المعارضه التركيه فبدت واضحه
بعد ان عاشت تركيا اجواء سياسيه شديده
السخونه والتوتر على وقع الزلزال السياسي
الذي احدثه الموقف الصادم
لرئيسه حزب
الجيد ميرال التي اعلنت رفضها ترشيحها
طاوله السته اي تحالف الاحزاب السته
المعارضه زعيم المعارضه رئيس حزب الشعب
الجمهوري كمالك للرئاسه كمرشح مشترك لهذه
الاحزاب المعارضه السته في الانتخابات
المقرره في الرابع عشر من مايو المقبل هذا
الموقف قبل بموقف استهجان واسع من الشارع
التركي وضربت موجه استقالات واسعه حزبها
وتم رصد استقالات اذن كبيره في صفوف هذا
الحزب
[موسيقى]
وفي تداعيات زلزال تركيا تصاعدت لتحذيرات
من وقوع زلزال مدمر في اسطنبول حيث افاد
خبيره الزلازل ناجي جورو باحتمال وقوع
زلزال تفوق قوته 10 درجات داعيا عمده
المدينه الى الاستعانه بالعلم لتقليص
الخسائر هذا الخبير التركي اكد انه هناك
فجوه زلزاليه في اسطنبول وعندما يتم سد
هذه الفجوه سيحدث زلزال مدمر يشبه زلزال
مرمره الكبير واشار الى ان الجانب الاسيوي
سيتاثر بنسبه اقل من الجانب الاوروبي في
الاماكن القريبه من الساحل حيث سيكون قويا
جدا
اظهرت لقطات وكاميرات المراقبه نشرت مؤخرا
لحظه انهيار مبنى سكني في زلزال قوي في
ملاطيا التركيه في السادس من فبراير
الماضي حيث تسببت قوه الزلزال في تفكك
المبنى المكون من سبعه طوابق ما اسفر عن
مقتل 29 شخصا وفقا لمسؤولين حكوميين
شاهدوا
[موسيقى]
هذا وحذر مختصون اتراك من حدوث تغير
ديمورفي كبير في البلاد بسبب موجات النزوح
لعشرات الالاف من ضحايا الزلزال وفيما
يفضل البعض الفرار من الولايات الجنوبيه
المتضرره نحو مدن وسط وشمال تركيا شهدت
كثير من القرى كذلك هجره عكسيه للباحثين
عن الامان
هذه المشاهد تتكرر يوميا خلال اولى ساعات
الصباحات انطاكيا المنكوبه فرار جماعي
للناجين من الزلزال الذي جعلها تاي من
اكبر المدن التضررا منهم من يملك وجهه
محدده ومنهم من سيحددها لاحقا خلال ساعات
الرحله الطويله بحثا عن الامان يعني
رفقاتي منهم ماتوا منهم راحوا لله الامر
بس
[موسيقى]
كل جيراني في هذه البنايه والحي غادروا
الى مدن اخرى انا كذلك تقرر هدم بيت
المتصدع وساذهب الى انقره واعيش هناك عند
اقاربه
كما السوريين الذين الف الترحاله دخل
الاتراك كذلك في هجره داخليه الى مدن
الشمال وعكسيه اعادت المئات منهم الى
القرى هنا بقريه جولباش بضواحيها تاي
ياملون النجاه بانفسهم من الزلزال وهزاته
المتتاليه لكن هذه السيده لا تامن الوضع
وتفضل الخيمه على البقاء داخل بيتها
منذ حدوث زلزال عدنا الى قرانه التي اصبحت
مزدحمه هي الاخرى هنا الوضع اقل خطوره من
مركز هاتاي لكني اخاف البقاء في البيت
لذلك انا في الخيمه
اما هذا الرجل فوجد نفسه لاجئا في خيمه
حتى وهو يعود الى قريته التي غادرها قبل
خمسه عقود من الاربعه وسبعين لها اليوم
فهذا من القريه بعيد
وسحب
رجعنا على مكان الاول باركين بالخيام مع
الندور ما عنا شيء وفقا للارقام الرسميه
فقد عاد اكثر من اربعين الف سوري طواعيه
الى سوريا فيما لم يتم الكشف بعد عن اعداد
المنكوبين من الاتراك وغيرهم ممن نزحوا
نحو مدن تركيه اخرى
تطمينات السلطات التركيه
بضروره سريعا لم توقف موجات النزوح لعشرات
الالاف من المنكوبين ما يؤشر الى حدوث
تغير ديموغرافي قد يزيد من متاعب الحكومه
في معالجه اثار الزلزال عبد القادر خربوش
العربيه
الثقافي الذي تتغنى به مدينه انطاكيا
التاريخيه اصبح اليوم مهددا بشكل كبير بعد
ان دمر زلزال الزلزال هذه المدينه وفق
صحيفه التي اعتبرت انه قبل الزلزال كانت
انطاكيا عاصمه اقليميه صاخبه تشتهر
بماكولاتها وكنائسها ومعابدها اليهوديه
ومساجدها التي تعود الى قرون لكنها اليوم
مدينه مدمره بالكامل المدينه القديمه
لانطاكيا دمرت بالكامل اذا بعد ان حافظت
على التعدديه الدينيه لسكانها من مسلمين
ومسيحيين ويهود اتراك واليوم معظمهم غادر
المدينه حيث فرت الجاليه اليهوديه باكملها
من المدينه مما قد يهدد الوجود اليهودي
الذي يعود تاريخه الى اكثر من 2000 عام في
انطاكيا وغادر اخرون ايضا فيما بما في ذلك
جميع الطوائف المسيحيه الارثوذكسيه
والكاثوليكيه والبروتستانتيه من هذه
المدينه تقريبا
[موسيقى]
التاسعه مستمرا نتابع فيها بعد قليل
والانتخابات 2024 هي المعركه الاخيره
ويقول احتاج 24 ساعه فقط لانهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد الى التاسعه في مقابله
خاصه مع العربيه قال المتحدث باسمي مجلسي
منبج العسكري شرفان درويش ان المعركه
المقبله مع تركيا ستكون مختلفه وكشف ان
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه قامت بتحضيرات
عسكريه ستفاجئ انقره
هناك فرق
تلقاني ما بين قوات وقوات الدوله التركيه
هذه التقنيات هي
التحضيرات التي قمنا بها وتدريب القوات
والتكتيكات التي سوف نتخذها سوف
تخلص الفجوه بيننا وبالتاكيد هنا على تصير
قناتكم اقول انها رزيل مره مقاومه سوف
تكون مختلفه اراده مقاتلنا واراده شعبنا
سوف تحدد للعالم كما كسرنا داعش سوف نكسر
الاحتلال الموجود ايضا هذه التجهيزات سوف
نتركها للتاريخ لان حصلت المعركه
فبالتاكيد العالم اجمع سوف يرى ونحن
تحضيراتنا سوف نكون نقول للشعبنا ونقول
للعالم اجمع كيف نقوم بتحضيرات فبالتاكيد
التفاصيل
حيث سوف تكون سريه
وبدورها وايضا بمقابله خاصه مع العربيه
كشفت القياديه في الرئاسه المشتركه لمجلس
سوريا الديمقراطيه امينه عمر كشفت عن
استعداد المجلس لاجراء حوار مع المعارضه
السوريه المدعومه من تركيا الموضوع الحوار
انا ذكرت انه استراتيجي بالنسبه لنا ليس
فقط مع النظام اذا كان هناك بالفعل نحن
نحتاج الى الحوار لما لا يكون مع النظام
ايضا مع المعارضه مع اي كل الاطراف نحن
مستعدين للحوار وليس مع النظام فقط فمن
جهه نحن بنحاور الجميع من اجل الخروج من
هذه الازمه ومن جهه اخرى نحن ننتقد سياسات
التي يتبعها النظام ضد شعبي
[موسيقى]
انا المرشح الوحيد القادر على انقاذ
امريكا من المتعصبين والاغبياء بهذه
الجمله اعلن دونالد ترامب عودته المبكره
للمشهد السياسي في امريكا والهدف
انتخاباته
كثيره بعضها جدليه كتصريحاته اعلنت ترامب
عن تحضيراته للترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه
القادمه بدءا من الداخل الامريكي ترامب
تحدث عن بناء مدن فاضله اطلق عليها مدن
الحريه ستحقق احلام الامريكيين وفق وصفه
وستعيد فتح الافاق وتعطي مئات الالاف من
الشباب وجميع العائلات التي تعمل بجد فرصه
جديده لملكيه المنازل ليس فحسب حيث ان
مخطط ترامب في 2024 سيشمل ايضا
الولادات الجديده في امريكا لافتا الى انه
سيطلب من الكونجرس دعم مكافات المواليد
للاباء الصغار للمساعده في اطلاقه طفره
مواليد جديده وفق وصفه اما عن الازمه في
اوكرانيا فقال ترامب بان لديه مخططا يبدو
انه سحري فهو بحاجه فقط لاربع وعشرين ساعه
لايقاف تلك الحرب بين كييف وموسكو وفق
قوله دائما لا بل سيحتاج الى عشر دقائق
فقط لاقناع قاده الدول في الاتحاد
الاوروبي برفع حجم مساعدتها المقدمه الى
اوكرانيا ان فاز في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله
قبل البيت الابيض سوف اقوم بتسويه الحرب
الكارثيه بين روسيا واوكرانيا وستتم
تسويتها بسرعه
[تصفيق]
ولن يستغرق الامر اكثر من يوم واحد اعرفوا
بالضبط ما ساقوله لكل منهما لقد تعاملت
معهما جيدا لقد تعاملت جيدا مع بوتين
اتذكرون عندما قالوا ان ترامب يعطي الكثير
لروسيا حقا قال لي بوتين في الواقع اذا
كنت صديقي فساكره ان اراك عدوي
وشدد ترامب على ان الولايات المتحده في
وضع اخطر من اي وقت مضى بسبب خطر استخدام
الاسلحه النوويه ونشوب حرب عالميه ثالثه
وتساءلت ترامب عن سبب تمويل اداره الرئيس
الحالي جو بايدن لكيف بهذه الاموال
الهائله في الوقت الذي يكتسب فيه انتصار
اوكرانيا على روسيا في هذا الصراع يكتسب
اهميه اكبر بكثير للدول الاوروبيه منه
للولايات المتحده هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه السابق ان الوقت قد حان لتتجاوز
الامه المرشحين السابقين لمنصب الرئيس في
تصريحات بدات تستهدف الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب
[موسيقى]
مع الان حسين الطاوود مراسلنا في العاصمه
الامريكيه واشنطن حسين اهلا بك ترامب قال
انه المرشح الوحيد القادر على انقاذ
امريكا وترامب قال كذلك انه خلال 24 ساعه
يستطيع ان يوقف الحرب في اوكرانيا كذلك ما
وقع كلام ترامب على الراي العام الامريكي
تحيه لك صهيب هذه ليست اول مره يعتبر
الرئيس السابق نفسه المرشح الاهم والمرشح
الافا والابرز حتى انه قال في خطابته في
هذا المؤتمر بانه المنقذ للجمهوريين وقت
يتحدث انه في عام 2016 كان صوتهم الان
سيكون المحارب من اجلهم والعدل من اجلهم
هكذا يقدم ترامب نفسه
ناخبين ناخبي هو ناخبين الجمهوريين الذين
يؤيدونه والذي تقريبا نسبتهم كما توضح
البعض
استطلاعات الراي اكثر من 50% تؤيدهم منذ
اليوم الاول للحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا
كان موقفه واضحا هو لا يؤيد تقديم
المساعدات بهذا السخه الكبير لاوكرانيا
لمواجهه روسيا حتى عبر عن اعجابه كما
نتذكر بالرئيس فلاديميرا بوتين هذه
التصريحات هي قديمه جديده وتصريحات معتاده
من قبل الامريكيين بالنسبه للرئيس دونالد
ترامب ولا جديد فيها بالنسبه لهم الا انه
يكررها ليقدم نفسه على انه المرشح الاكثر
تميزا بين جميع المرشحين نعم ولكنه يعني
هذه المره هاجم كذلك يا حسين هاجمت
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين على السواء
عندما قال انه الديمقراطيين ذوي النزعه
الحربيه وكذلك المتعصبين والاغبياء في
الحزب الجمهوري اي حزب الرئيس دونالد
ترامب ماذا يقصد ترامب هنا
كما يقول المحللون يريد ان يقطع الطريق عن
اي منافس وان كان من الحزب الجمهوري او
حتى من الحزب الديمقراطي اذا استطاع ان
يفوز بالانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب
الجمهوري ويكون مرشح الحزب الجمهوري ويضع
من الان الاسس لمواجهه المرشح الديمقراطي
ان كان الرئيس الحالي اذا كان هناك مرشح
اخر او بطبيعه الحال هجم الجميع كما تفضل
اعتبر ان ان العائلات السياسيه
المترسخه في الولايات المتحده ان كانت من
الحزب الجمهوريه تتحكم
من اجل مصالحها ومن اجل
محبتها للصين كما وصفهم مشيرا في طريقه
غير مباشره الى بايدن وعائلته
اجره
معتذرون عليه هناك الولايات المتحده طيب
هل هناك اي استطلاعات راي جديده بعد هذا
الكلام مره اخرى لترامب تقيس مدى حظوظه في
الانتخابات القادمه في 2024 ام ليس بعد
صهيب استطاعات الراي كما ذكرنا اكثر من
مره تختلف من بتوقيتها وتختلف بالمكان
الذي تجرى فيه ولكن حتى الان يبدو ان
ترامب في الحزب الجمهوري لدي هو الاوفر
حظا للفوز ثلاث سيما اذا كان هناك عدد
كبير من المرشحين الجمهوريين كما يقول
المحللون لان ذلك سيكون نعمه لتراب لان
اصوات الجمهوريه المعارضين له ستتقسم على
عدد كبير من المرشح سيحصل على مؤيدين ولكن
في نفس الوقت هناك من يقول بان هذا العدد
الكبير سيعطي افكار جديده حول الحزب
الجمهوري ولا من ذلك ولكن لا احد يستطيع
حتى الان ان يجزم بالنتيجه النهائيه حتى
تحدث الهجره الانتخابات التمهيديه في
الولايات الاولى
حسين طود من واشنطن
كنت اتحدث عن الوقت المناسب لانتخاب قاده
جديين مفكرين يتحدثون عن امريكا باعتبارها
الدوله الاكثر استثنائيه في تاريخ الحضاره
انهم لا يشوهونها ولا يقضون كل وقتهم في
التفكير في تويتر هذا ما كنت اتحدث عنه
نشيد فقط الى هذا العجل تايمز لتقول لنا
الجيش يقرر اغلاق المعابر الحدوديه مع
الضفه وغزه من الغد وحتى الاربعاء انحرف
قطار شحن يضماني عشره قاطره عن مساره في
مقاطعه كلارك بولايه اوهايو الامريكيه في
ثاني حادث لقطارات شحن في الولايه خلال
شهر
[موسيقى]
فنيا الان وبعد عام على صفعه الاوسكار
انتقم الممثل الكوميدي كريس روك من النجم
ويل سميث وذلك خلال حلقه كوميديه خاصه
عرضت على الهواء مباشره قائلا انه تلذذ
برؤيه سميث يتلقى الضربات في فيلمه الاخير
ايمن او تحرير ونقلت شبكه نتفليكس الحلقه
مباشره من مسرح هيبودروم حيث قال روك انه
شاهد في الموسمث فقط ليرسمث وهو يتعرض
للضرب خلال احداث الفيلم وكان يهدف يهدف
في فرح قائلا اضربه مره اخرى والتزم
ماروكا الصمت بشان الواقعه حتى قرب نهايه
الحلقه الخاصه التي استمرت ساعه ثم اتهمت
مثل الغضب الانتقائي وهو الاسم الذي اخترع
عنوانا لهذه الحلقه الخاصه
[موسيقى]
في بريطانيا اعلنا الامير هاري انه كان
يشعر دائما بالاختلاف الطفيف عن العائله
وان والدته الراحله الاميره ديانا كانت
لديها نفس المشاعر واكد دوقس وهو يعلق على
رد فعل الجمهور على مذكراته على انه لم
يكن ضحيه ولا كان يسعى للحصول على التعاطف
كما اثار الجدل من جديد حول حرب افغانستان
بعد ان كشف ان بعض الجنود البريطانيين لم
يكنوا راضين عن مشاركتهم في هذه الحرب
التاسعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز
عناوينها
اوكرانيا تتهم القوات الروسيه بتنفيذ
تدمير شامل في ضخمه وتؤكد صعوبه اجراء
المدنيين من هناك
[موسيقى]
البنتاجون يشكك بالرافعات الصينيه في
الموانئ الامريكيه قد تكون ادوات تجسس وفي
كين ترد روايه لعرقله التعاون
الرقعه الجغرافيه لتسمم الطالبات في ايران
تتسع لتشمل الجامعات جامعه الاحواز تعلن
عن اكثر من 300
اراده مقاتلنا واراده شعبنا مجلس منبج
العسكري يؤكد للعربيه اذا هاجمتنا تركيا
مجددا فالمعركه ستكون مفاجاه
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت ولكن فتره الاخبار
المسائيه على العربيه مستمره الان الى
العربيه 360 معكي ميسون مساء الخير ميسون
ماذا لديكم في 360 مساء الخير سهيل طبعا
معركه بخمه تتصدر الاخبار موضوع لغز تسميم
الطالبات في ايران بالاضافه طبعا الى
تصريحات الرئيس السابق ترامب وايضا وزير
الخارجيه السابق دائما ابقى معنا
لمتابعتنا المزيد من الزوايا حول هذه
الملفات معك ونعود ونلتقي مع المشاهدين
ايضا في اخبار الساعه بعد 360 اليك ميسور